welcome to another doctor Sadler's
honest review this is a series in which
I look at generally recent works in
philosophy as it applies to life
relationships career all those sorts of
matters so there's some overlap with
personal development leadership
organizational literature and today what
we're going to be looking at is
something really solidly within the
realm of philosophy pretty much focused
on personal identity it's Jade David
vellum ends on being me a very short
work so it's been recently brought out
this is this is 2020 so I'll tell you
what I think about this book
I generally begin by talking about 3 s's
style summary and structure now this is
a very short book it's only 91 pages
total with quite a few of these pages
actually just having a little bit of
stuff on them or or being kind of blank
and it's organized into chapters each of
the chapters is pretty short chapter one
is being glad I was born which has to do
with you know natality and what does it
mean to be a person who's being born
chapter 2 wanting to go on about
continuity chapter 3 fearing the end
thinking about well what it was it that
happens when we die who is it that dies
chapter 4 regretting what might have
been thinking about we might call them
counterfactuals or alternate selves
those who who we didn't become chapter 5
aspiring to authorship thinking about
one's life as something like you know
something that one is writing or
performing or developing chapter six is
focused on an agency in particular it's
called making things happen and then it
finishes up with Chapter seven wanting
to be loved too talking about well who
is it and why is that person loved and
what does that actually mean so each of
these is as the you know the little
blurb says a personal reflection on
daily life but also on sort of the big
picture items and and velman is leading
you through that the style is you know
pretty readable there's almost no
citations or bringing up other other
philosophers and velman tells us that
listen I've done enough work on these
sorts of things in my philosophical
scholarship these are going to be
first-person reflections so that's you
know more or less the structure and
summary of the work it's him musing and
meditating about ideas issues within
philosophy
ethics personal identity and and some
other related things I guess you could
say metaphysics epistemology and the you
know the style itself it's it's quite
readable I'm going to talk a bit more
about the style later on but there's
nothing here I think that's going to be
particularly difficult for the average
reader there's not really that much more
to say in this part about the work
what are the key ideas and insights of
this work I guess you could say that if
there's one thing to sum it all up it's
that what it means to be a person is
more complex than where we start out in
our thinking about it because what what
Veldman is doing with each of these
issues is starting with a topic or set
of topics and then kind of you know
meandering around and thinking about it
bringing in some distinctions that he
finds helpful puzzling about those as
well and he does arrive at some
conclusions here and there I'll just
give you an example here so he talks
about that the desire to eat a meal
later on and he says these these
feelings are investments in the future
in the sense that they envision
surviving until they can be resolved
discharged paid off and in envisioning
their future resolution they don't
identify the person who will experience
that they pick him out merely as the
subject of that experience in wanting
that I enjoy a bowl of chili at noon I
am referring to the subject who will
still be feeling this hunger at noon and
will remember I've been wanting this all
morning and I'm referring to that
subject and thinking of him as referring
to me I've been wanting irrespective of
who either of us may be so you know I
think that kind of gives you a little
flavor pun intended for you know what's
going on in this work it's all sorts of
you know little paths into talking about
mundane everyday experiences and there
are their bigger implications and so you
know he pitches this in his introduction
as a bunch of reflections on personhood
and you know other other things as well
he tells us that a person is a
convoluted sort of thing to be and you
know that's that's quite good so another
thing that comes up that I think is
quite interesting as you know the range
of
shoes that are being discussed you know
so he's delving into how we use the term
I in our language and you know what
personal identity over time actually is
issues of continuity what happens when
we make choices or commitments all of
these sorts of things are well worth
investigating and you know you you can't
approach them with this personal
invitation to philosophy I don't think
there's much more to say about key ideas
in this other than you know he is he
does have his finger on the pulse of a
number of different important topics
let's say
so let's talk about what's good about
this work the style is you know as I
mentioned quite readable I don't think
it's going to be particularly
challenging for the average reader this
is the sort of book that you could
easily read in an afternoon and have
plenty of time for taking little pauses
and thinking about what it is that
velman is telling us and it is indeed
raising and musing about and
investigating some really important
issues that have been recognized as such
throughout the history of philosophy and
it's doing so in a way that's that's
quite relatable I think for for a lot of
readers I won't say for all I'm going to
talk a little bit more about that in a
bit and you know I would say that if you
read through the work you are going to
find some some interesting insights here
and there and some useful analogies or
ways of digging into examples that you
probably then could could apply to your
own life the other thing that I'll say
is is early on in the work that I think
is a kind of funny and I'm gonna read
this verbatim he says academic
philosophers who read this book will say
but there are no arguments let me be the
first to say it there are no arguments
there are only observations of what
being a person is like for me and my
speculations as to why it might be like
that he says most of these observations
and speculations have appeared in my
academic publications sometimes
supported by more or less formal
arguments for many years I thought the
arguments were meant to convince the
reader but then I found myself oddly
unconcerned when few if any readers were
convinced I finally realized that I've
all along been reporting on personal
explorations composing dispatches from
an examined life my main hope has been
that these dispatches will be of
interest even without a demonstration
that they're true of persons in general
and so I kind of like that I think that
that's that's an interesting thing
to point out it's also sort of an
admission of the poverty of the work and
and of the perspectives involved in it
but I think it I think it is kind of
funny to say you know there are no
arguments in this and I'm not providing
that sort of thing because I've done
that elsewhere and I'm not really that
interested in the arguments and I never
really have been that interested in the
argument so I think that's kind of a
cool insight and you know here's here's
one other thing that's also coming from
this he says that I'm aware of and
embarrassed by the similarities between
the inner monologue of this book and
that of Descartes and his meditations
pretending to be a 21st century
Descartes would be ridiculous
I prefer to think that I'm simply
accepting as challenge to philosophize
from the inside out and so there's kind
of a humility there about the the
project and the prospects and and you
know how seriously we're supposed to
take that so these are these are all I'd
say good points about the work
what do I find problematic about the
work so here is where we get to the the
point of the review where I actually do
have quite a few things to say because
I'm going to say personally I did not
enjoy this book I found it without being
dry I found it dull and without being
tiresome I found it kind of tedious and
you know I think to myself as sort of
things he brings up in here
the time I devoted to this I could have
been doing so many other things and I
think that one of the big issues in the
work is revealed in the the references
that that development is making you know
he's got acknowledgments in here and
he's got you know some readings the
readings are all basically from either
his own stuff or analytic philosophy on
these issues you know and they are
important people to read like Harry
Harry Frank for a great great thinker
Thomas Nagel Bernard Williams well worth
reading but you know they're not the
only people who talk about this stuff
and I think they talk about it in more
interesting ways than develoment himself
does in this this work he also you know
talks about other people Elizabeth
Anscombe Daniel done it
Christine course card I was Murdoch and
you know bringing that up it's it's
interesting because it take for example
Iris Murdoch she's really fun and
interesting to read this just isn't and
I'm not quite sure exactly where it lies
or how much we can generalize it could
be that you read this book and you find
it really brilliant and insightful and
enjoyable and all those sorts of things
this might be a purely subjective set of
preferences but it's almost as if he
just didn't engage enough with the many
other thinkers who talk about these
issues
because there's an entire world out
there and and many of these issues go
way way back into philosophy and I
understand that velman really wants to
focus on his own experience but I think
that that may be another area where it's
offers as well because he's writing
about what it's like to be a professor
living in New York basically living out
this academic life that's kind of you
know going along quite quite well in
many respects and you know the baiting
about whether he should do this or that
and referencing playing tennis or
dancing and all that and myself
personally when I read this I'm like
yeah that's not the kind of person whose
life I actually care much about or want
to use to scrutinize these really
important issues of personal identity
and continuity over time and choices
that we make it's just you know there's
there's something kind of provincial
about it the sort of provincial 'ti that
you have in the people who view
everybody else is being provincials
because they're at the center of what
they take to be the world and it's just
not that it's not that interesting I
don't find it very illuminating to read
his his musings about these these issues
I didn't find I think there are
arguments in there I don't think that
they're particularly compelling and I
think that's where I have to sort of
leave it the other thing that I will say
about the work is if this is supposed to
be a personal invitation to philosophy
it doesn't feel like it's actually
bringing the reader in and it's the
reference to Descartes is really quite
extraordinary because there's so many
other people who did things like this
you know personal introspection I don't
think this has much resemblance to
Descartes meditations at all because
Descartes is really great at bringing
the reader in and making them say oh
yeah well that's that's really an issue
Descartes you might say has a sort of
despite the fact that Descartes says
rhetoric is no
decart is an amazing rhetorician in his
works this just doesn't do it and maybe
again maybe I'm totally off-base maybe
this is just a function of things not
syncing up right maybe most readers
really do enjoy this but I personally
have a hard time envisioning that as a
possibility so I don't see it as a
personal invitation to philosophy I see
it more as a let's let's see what David
bellman did when he was thinking about
stuff along the way and maybe some of
its relevant to our own lives but we do
really have to draw those those
implications out ourselves the other
last thing that I'll say about that is
this book is a 1295 so you're not
getting much in terms of the money that
you're spending on it you know that's
the sort of thing that if you wanted to
blow 1295 and like maybe read it on the
train or you know as you're sitting
waiting for appointments or something
like that it couldn't you know it could
be quite good to do but I just don't see
getting that much out of this this 1295
book
there is one aspect of the book that I
actually failed to mention in talking
about it and that is that it does have a
number of nice drawings by Emily
Bernstein but you know they're they're
kind of in pace with the rest of the
book they're her views on what
development is talking about I don't
recommend the book I don't say
across-the-board don't get it if you're
into this sort of confessional
literature let's call it confessional
light with some musings about
philosophical topics it couldn't be bad
to get I just think that your time and
money and thought could be way better
spent on other philosophy things so I
give it a sort of qualified don't get
this book if you're into this sort of
thing by all means get it but I don't
think most readers are going to find it
all that rewarding to read this
you